things have completely exploded with
Steve Bannon CEO of Trump's presidential
campaign executive director of
right-wing news site Breitbart
he's got a real problem with Jews if you
believe a number of different people who
claim to know about it and this relates
to the issue of Trump not being
anti-semitic necessarily his daughter is
Jewish his son-in-law is Jewish his
grandkids are Jewish but he is
surrounding himself with people that are
allegedly anti-semitic and he's also
really emboldened anti-semitism among
his followers and this is going to be
supposedly Steve Bannon is going to be a
one of trumps closest advisors during
his upcoming presidency there are now so
many stories about Steve Bannon
including the fact that according to his
ex-wife he complained that there were
too many students at the archer school
for girls which is a very elite
expensive private school in Los Angeles
and apparently he didn't want his kids
going there because there were just a
lot of Jewish kids that he didn't want
his kids around
according to bannon's ex-wife
mary-louise picard in a court
declaration during their divorce quote
the biggest problem he had with Archer
is the number of Jews that attend he
said he doesn't like the way they raised
their kids to be whiny brats and that he
didn't want the girls going to school
with Jews Bannon reportedly also
complained that another elite school had
quote too many Chanukah books in the
library now there are critics saying
David this is something his ex-wife said
in divorce proceedings to make him look
bad if you want to make your soon-to-be
ex-husband look bad in court you don't
come out with super specific stuff about
Jews you would say something that would
be more influential maybe to the court
and getting a more favorable child
support or alimony sediment settlement
or whatever you don't come up with
really specific comments about Jews at a
school and by the way Glenn Beck is
really being upfront about this Glenn
Beck a right winger who is very
concerned about Donald Trump and the
appointments that are going on he said
oh yeah there's no doubt that Steve Ben
and is connected to white nationalism
check this out Steve Bannon wants to
burn it down and you will if you listen
to this show you will learn what he
wants to replace it with he's a
nightmare
and he's the chief adviser to the
President of the United States you know
if people really want to in the press
would like to call Donald Trump a racist
you might want to stop on that one and
just spend a little time on Bannen
because Bannon has a clear tie to white
nationalists clear tie you okay he said
his business for the yeah they all right
yeah he's sort of built Breitbart as a
platform for the alt-right
he is on record saying that he's on
record defining the alt-right he knows
what it is he is a guy who has it wants
to tear this system down and replace it
with a new system he is he is a
frightening no no he is a terrifying man
are we really supposed to be surprised
that an ultra-right conspiracy theorist
is allegedly an anti-semite I mean they
often go together and former KKK leader
David Duke really really likes it this
is from yesterday on the rents radio
networks David Duke show sounds like a
just absolutely tremendous show people
are telling me he is really happy about
Steve Bannon being involved in the Trump
White House check this out
interesting enough mr. bannon is being
chosen to be the top strategist in other
words basically the closest adviser to
Donald Trump in terms of the ideas of
the Trump revolution I think that's a
good sign because I think mr. bannon has
really been right on about a lot of
issues facing European Americans he's
really talked about the and supported in
some ways they all right
although I think they've supported some
of the members of our so-called members
there all right
like meelo who is not really
representative of the alright at the
same time he certainly understands that
immigration is a destructive force in
America of the Western world they have
been savagely attacking Merkel
and of course Trump himself yeah so I
know that the reaction is always Pat
listen Trump disavow David Duke Trump's
daughter as Jewish as grandkids are
Jewish that's all fine well and good but
it becomes harder and harder to say that
there is nothing to discuss when Trump
has mobilized and excited white
supremacists like no candidate for a
very long time people like David Duke
like Trump they liked from selections
etc etc it's fine that Donald Trump is
not personally anti-semitic we don't
really need to even explore whether he
is or isn't look at who's emboldened by
the Trump will be administration and
there's some more reluctant Trump
supporters who say that he'll drop his
more xenophobic rhetoric once he takes
office yeah until he doesn't have Steve
Bannon in his ear and until people like
David Duke renounce him yeah there's no
reason to believe that if Duke remains
happy about what you are doing and about
who you're picking then that is still
cause for concern and we're seeing just
record hundreds and hundreds of
anti-semitic attacks being reported to
the anti-defamation league and the KKK
planning a parade which is what I want
to talk about next